the day after russian troops invaded
ukraine russia's ambassador to the
european union claimed that it was an
operation to enforce peace
since then entire cities in ukraine have
been destroyed hundreds of civilians
have been killed according to the united
nations and russia has been accused of
war crimes is peace possible while bombs
continue to drop and what's russia's end
goal in ukraine i'll ask russian
ambassador to the european union
vladimir chisof in an upfront special
[Music]
[Music]
vladimir chesov thank you for joining me
on upfront on february 25th you claimed
russia's actions in ukraine were not an
invasion but quote a peace enforcement
special military operation
since then thousands have died more than
three and a half million people have
fled ukraine and tensions are higher in
europe than they've been since world war
ii
how is this an enforcement of peace
well indeed i can confirm it is a
special military operation rather than
an invasion
and of course certainly not an act of
aggression
you say thousands of people died
well
i will say that
uh
according to uh uh un sources
uh
the uh civilian casualties
uh
during this last month have been
uh
less than a thousand but still every
every life counts i agree
uh also the
almost 14 000 uh civilian lives
that were lost in the
preceding eight years in donbass
as a result of uh
uh actions by the ukrainian army and uh
the so-called
uh nationalist uh
battalions
so the u.n high commissioner for human
rights recorded actually 2 421
civilian casualties in the country uh
925 killed and
1496 injured but to the bigger point
you're making here if you see
violence in the dunbas region
why invade the whole country why
uh why attack lev for example
well uh the answer is quite simple and
the reasons uh are quite logical
uh
uh if
uh
the situation in donbass proper
is settled without any change in the
uh policies of the kiev regime
then
that uh
boundary between the two
now independent republics
of donbass and
the
and the ukrainian uh
government-controlled territory would
become
would have become
a
constant source of tension and
clashes uh
including the use of
firepower and military actions
with russian forces everywhere with
tanks rolling through cities would you
in retrospect still say that this has
been an enforcement of peace
actually
the tanks are not rolling through cities
the
russian armed forces
are acting
very
i would even say delicately
without
actually entering big cities
like key for harkov
the idea is not
occupation it is not destruction
of
civilian
quarters it is not
taking uh civilians as hostages the way
uh the ukrainian nationalist battalions
are currently doing uh it is to
[Music]
wipe out
the
central uh the points of command and
control of the ukrainian armed forces
and to
ensure demilitarization of the country
the problem on the ground today is
that
the opposing side the ukrainian army and
uh
more importantly those
so-called territorial defense battalions
the nationalists
some of them openly neo-nazis
they
use
the civilian population as a human
shield they establish
their tanks
apcs and artillery
among
residential
areas in inside the residential areas
among the buildings where people still
live
and they take those civilians hostage
when
when russia
proposed
to have humanitarian corridors
established uh it was uh the nationalist
groups that prevented people from
leaving uh a long time so there is there
is considerable i i hate to interrupt
you there but there's just considerable
disagreement uh with this account not
just by ukrainian sources but by the
international community human rights
organizations journalists almost every
everyone who has stood in opposition to
this uh this this these proceedings but
certainly that account but i have to
move on on february 15th president
vladimir putin said that russia did not
want
war in europe on february 16th you
yourself were quoted as saying there
will be no escalation in the coming week
or in the week after that or in the
coming month and then less than 10 days
later
your country invaded ukraine what
happened
well first of all we didn't invade
ukraine in the sense of the word
but
there was no uh
other option than to launch this special
military operation i'm i'm sorry to say
that because
actually up to the last moment
as you uh can see from my own statements
and the those of
of president putin and foreign minister
lavrov
we wanted to avoid this course of events
but
now
with the benefit of hindsight i can
confirm that the ukrainian
uh well let me ask you about that though
sir
let me let me finish i i will but i i i
i just want to ask you a question about
a point preparing to launch an offensive
attack on the donbass republics
so what actions russia the russian side
took
was to prevent that uh bloody another
bloody mass cycle in donbass
your contention is that based on your
remarks that you didn't know and that
president putin didn't know intelligence
reports were saying that this was going
to happen people around the world were
saying this was going to happen
one could look at these developments and
not say oh this was a last-minute change
of action but rather that the russian
government was simply dishonest about
what was going on how do you make sense
of or respond to this idea that
intelligence reports were saying that
there was an invasion coming and then
there was an invasion coming
well whose intelligence reports
intelligence are you sure many
intelligence reports tend to be
misleading as
modern history has shown
let me remind you of 2003 uh the war in
iraq and the
uh the white powder in the hands of uh
colin powell
yeah that would be that would be an
example of a dishonest inaccurate
intelligence report i agree but in this
case it was accurate they said you were
going to invade and you invaded so to
sum again this would make it hard to
trust the russian government to depend
on your analysis or your word or for
even you as a diplomat if you didn't
know it was going to happen how can we
in future conversation and future
analysis and future processes of
diplomacy trust that you know what's
going on with your own government
uh it's not
an issue of somebody knowing in advance
uh what the plans would be and what the
actual situation it's the course of
events
the uh
intelligence evidence that we
received that the ukrainian army was
planning an offensive attack on the two
donbass republics
that
was the last throw and i would even then
to that
remember
uh president zelinski appearing at the
munich
security conference a few days before
this uh
event unfolded and he openly claimed
that
he does not exclude
ukraine becoming a nuclear power
obtaining nuclear weapons and the whole
audience
all the western participants they uh
stood up and uploaded that speech
how should uh russia
uh
view that as support of
the destruction of the non-proliferation
regime of
an immediate threat
next door to russia
one could actually argue that any any
disruption of a non-proliferation
agreement will be coming from russia
ukraine yielded all of its nuclear
weapons in in exchange partly for
sovereignty and that's the very thing
that's being violated now but but we
have to keep going here the u.n
international court of justice uh in the
hague has ordered your country to halt
its invasion of ukraine because of a
lack of evidence to justify the war the
council of europe has expelled your
country from its human rights body and
the u.n has overwhelmingly voted to
reprimand russia's actions in ukraine
are your government's actions not a
glaring violation of international law
uh of course not
first of all the council of europe did
not expel russia russia made a decision
to to withdraw from the council of
europe
that was
the day before any
actions were taken in strasbourg
secondly
the international court of justice has
taken its decision
on a
wrong
legally
unsound basis
so
we do not have
any intention of
following up on that
and in the united nations uh look at
what's happening
around the russian draft of a security
council resolution on the humanitarian
situation
western countries are trying to
to block it unfortunately because
it is biased and we know
that
western
countries uh
in particular the united states
are
trying to influence uh
many uh developing countries and other
countries of the world
uh into uh following their uh
their version of events and their course
of action which is uh totally unfair and
does not do credit
uh either to the united states or
all those other western countries that
are following suit yeah just just a
quick uh just a quick fact check uh as
on march 16th several weeks into the
invasion the council of europe expelled
russia from the continent's foremost
human rights body
they said the russian federation ceases
to be a member of the council of europe
as of today that's march 16th at the 47
nation organization
did that also the international court of
justice says that there wasn't
sufficient evidence of a claim of
genocide to justify russia's actions and
so forth but again let's keep moving
because earlier this month russian
forces bombed a maternity hospital a
maternity hospital in spite of an
agreement to a 12-hour pause intended to
allow civilians to escape now
the associated press the world health
organization the u.n amnesty
international human rights watch they
all affirm this claim there are
witnesses to this uh everyone has
declared that this has happened uh are
you saying that it didn't happen or are
you saying that it's not a war crime to
bomb a maternity hospital
well uh this is uh
a flagrant
case of
fake news spread spreading by western
media and western governments
the russian army did not bomb a
maternity hospital in mariupol or
anywhere else
that maternity hospital
had been
occupied by uh the azov nationalist
battalion
since the end of february that is about
10 days before the alleged
uh bombing
took place
there and they kicked out all
all the doctors all the pregnant women
all the newborn babies and established
themselves inside that maternity
hospital
that is a fact
that is actually if you look closely
even to the uh
to the video footage of the situation
there
are don't you have any questions
why after this bombing all the trees in
the garden in front of the
maternity hospital are left standing
why there is only one single
ostensibly pregnant woman being carried
by uh people who have nothing to do with
the medical profession and nobody else
well and the the house behind that the
building behind them is uh vacant there
is nobody else just just so that i'm
clear and i understand because you're
saying that there was one
only one woman first of all there were
images of several blood-stained uh
pregnant mothers uh fleeing a blown-out
hospital we've seen images are you
saying i just want to be for i just want
to ask for clarity's sake are you
suggesting that those images are fake
yes okay let's keep going uh
what about the bomb that was dropped uh
last week on a theater in maria paul
where hundreds of civilians were
sheltering we have satellite images
easily visible from an aircraft that
revealed that outside of this building
painted in very large letters was the
word
children
that's a war crime no
yes it was a war crime to to
paint the
those uh letters
uh and the crime uh was uh perpetrated
by the same as of battalion
that uh took a
few hundred
civilians
put them into the basement of the
theater
and on top of that they established
their headquarters
in the building
there was no
aerial bombardment in mariupol
that can be easily checked by satellite
images
the uh explosion that
took place in front of the
of the theater
was a result of a detonation
of a bomb or an artillery shell placed
there
by those who had occupied
the
the upper
uh section of the theater and actually
as a result of that explosion the
civilians that were kept hostages uh
hostage
downstairs in the basement
they uh could not leave
and uh
did anyone
say how many casualties were there in
the theater
what we know for sure is that hundreds
of children were sheltering there what's
indisputable is that a bomb went off
you're simply suggesting that russia is
not responsible for it that uh stands
again in sharp contrast to other
accounts to expert opinion to outside
journalists and to the very satellite
images that you say would would excapate
you but let's keep going uh there have
been reports that ukrainian citizens are
being forcibly taken to russia uh forced
deportations are recognized again as a
crime against humanity according to the
international criminal court uh is your
country taking people against their will
no
actually we
are taking people according to their
wishes and russia
the russian forces established
humanitarian corridors out of marijuana
in different directions
in the direction of the donbass people's
republics in russia
and in the direction of the
government-controlled territory
and it is the
nationalist battalions that are
preventing people from leaving towards
russia
uh
that is a crime
uh whereas uh
you know over 350 000
citizens of uh donbass and ukraine
uh they voluntarily left
to russia and are accommodated there by
uh the
various russian regional authorities
again the claim here is that between
four thousand and forty five hundred
more poor residents were forcibly uh
moved but we'll continue to monitor this
uh that is uh uh a claim that has
nothing to do with reality okay well
we'll continue to watch uh and see if
this is indeed another violation of
international law let's talk about
another group of people who have been
suffering as a result of this war uh
russians
more than 15 000 people have already
been detained across russia as a result
of peacefully protesting your
government's war on ukraine uh human
rights groups say that police have used
excessive force and in some instances
degrading treatment and even torture
do ordinary russians have a right to
disagree
uh of course uh russians have a right to
agree or disagree actually the level of
support of the government's uh position
uh in this situation has grown
and the latest figure is 74 percent of
uh russians according to
an influential polling uh result
is uh in favor uh fully of what is doing
uh what the government and the president
are doing
uh i don't know where you got the figure
of fifteen thousand
i think it's fifteen thousand
fifteen thousand yeah to be to be
precise fifteen thousand and eighty
eight detentions have occurred at
anti-war actions in russia starting from
february 24th so even if this 74 number
that you're saying is accurate even if
the overwhelming number of russians
support this war there's still dissent
and it seems that if your number's right
then an overwhelming number of people
who are opposing the war are being
detained for it
uh well uh the latest show of support
was quite visible last sunday
if you saw the image
from
the luzhniki olympic stadium there were
203 thousand people purchasing
participating in a rally and concert in
support of
what
russia and its army are doing
of course there are cases of
disagreement but i think the figure of
15 000 is a gross exaggeration how many
how many people have been arrested for
anti-war actions then
what number is more
i don't know it's i think it's a
very small number and i will i need to
add that the russian police
is uh employing
very i would say uh
light uh measures uh to
to dispel those
protests uh incomparably uh
more humane than many of the police
sections in even in the european union
not to say other countries
last week we saw reports that there had
been progress in negotiations between
russia and ukraine but as german foreign
minister analina bearbach said if one
side speaks about peace talks and at the
same moment bombards hospitals and
buildings then this is not really about
talks
uh what will it take for the kremlin to
withdraw troops from ukraine
well uh you know i'm a bit skeptical
about those stocks uh so far
because the ukrainian side
first of all they ask for those stocks
to start
then they fail to show up for
a day or two
then when they ultimately show up they
have no
instructions to to proceed
and then one of the negotiating team
is shot upon return from the first round
showed by
the ukrainian security
then
they
say one thing one day
a totally different thing next day
and
back in kiev
zelensky and his
cronies are saying uh different things
every every single day
some could argue that that's no
different than saying that there's no
invasion happening and then a few days
later invading a country but at the end
of the day what is the end goal in
ukraine is it a pro-russian government
in kiev
no actually what we want
is a peaceful democratic ukraine where
the rights of all people
uh
including language rights would be
respected
because today in today's ukraine
uh the russian language which is spoken
by more than a half of of the population
is actually
has actually been
uh
uh
pressured out of the
of the education system of the media
uh and of any uh formal communication
which uh i think is a clear violation of
the existing
uh european uh rules and legislation
we want ukraine to be
a neighbor that would not threaten
russia anymore
uh we want uh ukraine to be neutral as
it was
uh declared to be when it got
independence
and when
you mentioned uh the
uh
without naming it
uh the budapest memorandum of 94 about
the nuclear potential it was not
ukrainian
nuclear
assets it was soviet nuclear assets that
were
transferred to russia from ukraine from
belarus and other former soviet
republics
so
that
memorandum was based
on the declaration of independence of
ukraine of 1991
which proclaimed that ukraine would be a
neutral and non-aligned country
mr chisoff thank you so much for
spending time with us at upfront thank
you all right
everyone that is our show up front we'll
be back next week